- Good morning and welcome.
My name is Sharon Kugler,
and I'm the Yale University chaplain.
It's a true privilege to assist
with this service of remembrance
honoring those among the first women
in Yale College who have
died before they could mark
this 50 year milestone.
As I visited the extraordinary exhibit
over at the Sterling
Memorial Library last week,
it was striking to see
how much the first women
who came to Yale to get an education
actually educated Yale.
What they endured, what you endured,
and how you became the women
whose remarkable minds and hearts
have touched and improved the world
is most humbling and deeply inspiring.
The generations of women
that have and will continue
to follow you do not walk in your shadow.
They are walking in your light.
This morning, we have
come together to carve out
a little time and space
to nurture our hearts.
There's much to celebrate
outside of these walls,
and yet, we are also
mindful that our circle
of celebration is incomplete.
In the midst of the
festivities of this weekend,
our hearts also ache.
There are pieces of us,
sisters, who are missing.
For a little while, we will
take some time to pause
in loving remembrance for
those who have left this earth
and are not here to
share in the many facets
of this weekend.
We miss their voices here,
and we honor their memory
as being part of the firsts.
Let this space be a comfort to you
as your thoughts drift
wherever they need to be.
May you feel welcome to
participate in any way
that brings you a sense
of peace in this moment.
We have brought together
different elements
for this service.
There is much music to soothe,
some spoken word and
poetry, prayer and prose,
a lovingly curated backdrop,
and most importantly,
there'll be quiet time and space
for you to hold yourself
and one another gently
as you remember those who have died.
We have lit a candle to
bring light to each name.
Some of our sisters left very young,
others had more life, more decades.
I invite you now to breathe in and out,
to be fully present in this space
with yourself and one another.
Let us begin.
(peaceful guitar and cello music)
♪ Spirit of life ♪
♪ Come unto me ♪
♪ Sing in my heart ♪
♪ All the stirrings of compassion ♪
♪ Blow in the wind ♪
♪ Rise in the sea ♪
♪ Spirit of life ♪
♪ Come to me, come to me ♪
♪ Roots hold me close ♪
♪ Wings set me free ♪
♪ Spirit of life ♪
♪ Come to me, come to me ♪
♪ Come unto me ♪
♪ Sing in my heart ♪
♪ Giving life the word of justice ♪
♪ Blow in the wind ♪
♪ Rise in the sea ♪
♪ Spirit of life ♪
♪ Come to me, come to me ♪
♪ Roots hold me close ♪
♪ Wings set me free ♪
♪ Spirit of life ♪
♪ Come to me, come to me ♪
- [Reader] In Blackwater
Woods, by Mary Oliver.
Look, the trees are
turning their own bodies
into pillars of light,
are giving off the rich
fragrance of cinnamon
and fulfillment,
the long tapers of cattails are bursting
and floating away over the
blue shoulders of the ponds,
and every pond, no
matter what its name is,
is nameless now.
Every year everything I have ever learned
in my lifetime leads back to this.
The fires and the black river of loss
whose other side is salvation,
whose meaning none of us will ever know.
To live in this world you must be able
to do three things.
To love what is mortal,
to hold it against your bones knowing
your own life depends on it,
and, when the time comes to let it go,
to let it go.
- We will be reading from
the First Covenant, Psalm 90.
I will read the first line,
and we'd ask you to respond
in the italicized lines.
Lord, you have been our dwelling
place in all generations.
- [Audience] Before the
mountains were brought forth,
or ever you had formed
the earth and the world,
from everlasting to
everlasting you are God.
- You turn us back to dust, and say,
"Turn back, O mortal ones."
- [Audience] For a thousand
years in your sight
are like yesterday when it is past,
or as a watch in the night.
- You sweep them away.
They are like a dream,
like grass which is
renewed in the morning.
- [Audience] In the morning
it flourishes and is renewed,
in the evening it fades and withers.
- Teach us to number our days
that we may receive a heart of wisdom.
- [Audience] Satisfy us in the morning
with your steadfast love,
so that we may rejoice
and be glad all our days.
- Let the favor of the
Lord our God be upon us,
and establish the work
of our hands, together.
- [All] O Lord, establish
the work of our hands.
- Amen.
(soft cello music)
(singing in foreign language)
- The Continuous Life, by Mark Strand.
What of the neighborhood
homes awash in a silver light,
of children hunched in the bushes,
watching for signs, the
grownups, for surrender,
signs that the irregular pleasures
of moving from day to day,
of being adrift on the swell of duty,
have run their course?
O parents, confess to your little ones
the night is a long way off
and your taste for the mundane grows.
Tell them your worship of
household chores has barely begun.
Describe the beauty of shovels
and rakes, brooms and mops.
Say there will always be
cooking and cleaning to do,
that one thing leads to
another, which leads to another.
Explain that you live
between two great darks,
the first With an ending,
the second without one.
That the luckiest thing
is having been born,
that you live in a blur of hours and days,
months and years, and
believe it has meaning,
despite the occasional
fear you are slipping away
with nothing completed,
nothing to prove you existed.
Tell the children to come inside,
that your search goes on
for something you lost,
a name, a family album that fell
from its own small matter into another,
a piece of the dark that
might have been yours,
you don't really know.
Say that each of you tries to keep busy,
learning to lean down close
and hear the casual breathing
of earth and feel its available
languor come over you,
wave after wave, sending
small tremors of love
through your brief, undeniable selves,
into your lives, and beyond.
- Uh-oh.
My bad.
Let us remember and give thanks
for those of our classmates who have died
and who blessed us by their
presence in our lives.
From the class of 1971, Karen Hamity,
Cynthia Jordan,
Karen Katzman,
Cathy Kunin,
Ellen Lerner,
Darryle Pollack,
Marcy Roseman,
Merle Roth Rubin,
Christina Zuni Gierlotka Wynings.
- From the class of 1972,
Anita Dixon,
Maryse Baptiste Edwards,
Gail Frishman,
Sarita Wardlaw Henry,
Anya Hilliard,
Susan Lifshutz,
Marjorie Marks,
Elizabeth Montgomery-Heinz,
Sherry Nichols,
Pamela Horton Oliva,
Judy Radspinner,
Evadne Flip Sanichas,
Rosanna Sattler.
- From the class of 1973,
Jocelyn Chang,
Jane Curtis,
Stephanie Hill Fish,
Lise Goldberg,
Christa Hansen,
Gail Horowitz,
Olga Howard,
Allison Boucher Krebs,
Susan McClure,
Susan O'Connor,
Diane Polan,
Darial Sneed,
and Diane Straus.
Is Elga's daughter Lauren with us?
- It's truly been a transformative weekend
to be here with you all.
I hope you'll bear with
me for a few minutes
in this wonderful ceremony
so I can tell you a little
bit more about my mother.
My mother lived her early
life in Berlin, Germany.
To understand my mother, truly,
you had to understand her mother.
She was an amazing woman, Lisa Steinherz.
As early as 1930, she
realized that the family
would eventually need to leave Germany,
and she started to plan.
Part of that planning included
hiring a British governess
for my mother and her younger brother
so that by the time she came to America
in 1936, at the age of 12,
she was fluent in English.
She had learned English in three years.
I read from her journal.
1933 came into my sheltered
middle-class childhood
as a welcome diversion.
My parents, suddenly preoccupied
with daily developments
for the first time, more or
less abandoned my brother
and me to the care of our
(speaking in foreign language).
Only she now stood between
me and independence.
I still vividly recall
the pleasure I derived
by not eating what she put on my plate.
By playing hide and go
seek, leading the poor girl
to believe me lost, and
by defying the bedtime
that had been rigidly
established by my mother.
My brother and I sensed an air
of excitement in the house.
She started school at a Montessori,
which was eventually closed by the Nazis.
When the Montessori
school was ordered closed
shortly after Hitler came to power,
I was enrolled in an elementary school run
by the Jewish community of Berlin.
I was thrilled.
This was real school at
last, formal classrooms,
regular recess, grades,
and above all, homework.
On the way home from school,
I passed billboards with
anti-Semitic cartoons.
My good friend Susie and I
were inseparable 12 year olds in 1936.
Quite accustomed to being
barred from our favorite parks
by signs proclaiming, for Aryans only.
By the time we arrived
after a six-day crossing
of the Atlantic, I was delighted
to step ashore in New York.
Susie went to England rather than America,
and an active correspondence was begun.
September 1937.
Dear Susie, I hope you don't think
that I've forgotten you,
but since I am in school,
there is very little time to write.
The high school is prima, first class.
I have the choice of
taking the academic course
or the general course.
I will take the academic course,
because I want to go to college.
Because of this, I will
take French and Latin
instead of typing and stenography.
I was able to choose
between painting and music.
I chose music.
I will also take English,
mathematics, physics,
and social studies, that is,
geography, history,
politics, all mixed together.
Virgina Woolf wrote, for we
think back through our mothers,
if we are women.
Helen Epstein wrote the
book, "Where She Came From,"
about her mother's
experiences in the Holocaust.
I always felt protective of my mother,
because she had lost so
many friends and family.
I imagined what it must have been like,
because she hardly ever talked about it.
She said she didn't remember.
Helen Epstein wrote,
I wore the clothes my mother made for me,
read the books she read,
valued what she thought good.
I shared my life with her for a long time,
long after adolescence
should have ruptured the bond
between us, I shared her loves,
her disappointments, and her memories.
She was the engine behind my energy,
my defender when I needed one, my solace.
When the break finally
came, it was brutal.
We came apart in a great explosion
that required years to repair.
In her last years, my mother lived
in a retirement community in Lexington,
while my father was sinking into dementia.
It was during that time and
while I was living close by
that my mother and I rejoined.
We had a standing Tuesday dinner date.
Sometimes I picked up
my young granddaughter,
her great-granddaughter,
Ellaria, from daycare
and she joined us too.
Our dinners were times of healing.
My father died late in 2013.
Shortly after, my mother
was diagnosed with cancer.
Her last weeks were a gift
we shared with each other.
In October 2014, I stayed
with her while she received hospice care.
She dictated these last thoughts to me
as I sat in bed with her
and as I knit a layette
for her soon to be born
second grand-daughter, Nadia.
See if I can find it.
November 2014.
I would like my family and friends
to know that I am grateful
for the man I married
and the parents I had.
I could not be more appreciative
of my three children
and my seven grandchildren,
and my one great-grandchild, Ellaria,
and my great-grandchild to come.
I wish everyone could be
as lucky as I have been
in having such a family
and such good friends.
I am appreciative of Brookhaven,
where she was living.
It has enriched the last years of my life
with new friendships and activities.
I have loved the times we
all spent in Wellfleet.
I have had a very scattered career,
but I enjoyed all phases of it,
teacher, administrator,
lawyer, mediator, and writer.
It is time for somebody my age to move on.
I hope that all of you will
carry on the values I hold,
peace and justice and equal
opportunity, Elga Wasserman.
She's buried in Grove Street Cemetery.
It's a beautiful spot.
Thank you.
(peaceful music)
- We remember them.
Please join for the responsive reading,
the words in italics.
This is by Roland Gittelsohn
in "The Gates of Prayer."
In the rising of the sun,
and in its going down.
- [Audience] We remember them.
- In the blowing of the wind
and in the chill of winter.
- [Audience] We remember them.
- In the opening buds and
in the rebirth of spring.
- [Audience] We remember them.
- In the blueness of the sky
and in the warmth of summer.
- [Audience] We remember them.
- In the rustling of leaves
and in the beauty of autumn.
- [Audience] We remember them.
- In the beginning of the
year and when it ends.
- [Audience] We remember them.
- When we are weary and
in need of strength.
- [Audience] We remember them.
- When we are lost and sick at heart.
- When we have joys we yearn to share.
- [Audience] We remember them.
- So long as we live, they too shall live,
for they are now a part of us.
- [Audience] As we remember them.
- Throughout the planning
of this celebration,
we heard from several first women
who could not join us today
because of illness,
disability, or incapacity.
Some are caregivers themselves
for partners and spouses.
As we honor the memory
of those who have died,
let us also remember those
in need of our support,
in need of a kind word,
in need of a prayer.
As you let the beauty and
emotion fill your hearts
during this song of healing,
I invite you to send your
most loving of thoughts
to those who could not be here,
and pray their names quietly to yourself.
(gentle music)
(singing in foreign language)
♪ May the source of strength ♪
♪ Who blessed the ones before us ♪
♪ Help us find the courage ♪
♪ To make our lives a blessing ♪
♪ And let us say amen ♪
(singing in foreign language)
♪ Bless those in need of healing with ♪
♪ The renewal of body ♪
♪ The renewal of spirit ♪
♪ And let us say, amen ♪
- Amen.
We are coming to the
close of this service,
and I'd like to thank everyone
who had a hand in its planning.
The committee was hard at
work across many miles,
but always, even at a distance,
with love and care in mind.
Thank you, as well, to all
those behind the scenes
who handled logistics
and forgotten details.
None of this would have been possible
without your patient touch.
Deep gratitude to our readers
and incredible musicians.
Nicoletta, Yun, beautiful
Martina, you blessed us.
Thank you.
Truly, you gave us balm
for our weary souls.
Finally, to each one of you
gathered here this morning,
thank you for coming, for
being present to each other
while we lifted up the
names of Yale's first women
who have died.
As you journey out of this space
into the throes of continuing celebration,
and then back to your daily lives,
remember the gift you were to Yale,
and trust that your brave light
and steadfast pursuit
of truth lives on today.
Please know that you
are welcome to stay here
as long as you may need.
Continue to share stories.
Continue to share your remarkable selves.
May you imagine a tomorrow
where memories of your
departed sisters rest safe
and sheltered in the warmest of places,
where hope is always abundant
and sustaining to you.
My friends, I bid you peace.
(gentle cello and guitar music)
♪ Amazing grace ♪
♪ How sweet the sound ♪
♪ That saved a wretch like me ♪
♪ I once was lost but now I'm found ♪
♪ Was blind but now I see ♪
♪ Twas grace that taught
my heart to fear ♪
♪ And grace my fears relieved ♪
♪ O how precious did that grace appear ♪
♪ The hour I first believed ♪
♪ Through many dangers, toils and snares ♪
♪ I have already come ♪
♪ Tis grace that brought
me safe thus far ♪
♪ And grace will lead me home ♪
♪ Amazing grace ♪
♪ How sweet ♪
♪ Your sound ♪
- Thank you so much.
One last invitation.
If you had written a
remembrance for a classmate,
you are welcome to come
and take one candle.
Please watch your step, but
we would love these candles
to live in hope in your households.
Thank you.
(gentle music)
(crowd chattering)